cameras rolling sounds good I mean I
wish I could say that none of us saw
this coming but the truth is all of us
for sure did all of us for sure did I
mean we knew it was all just a matter of
time
you know after Alex Jones we knew it was
in the cards for a lot of people we'd
already been demonetised quite a bit not
to mention the the restrictions
restricted modes been really bad for us
and outright suspensions we had no
choice they forced her hand creating mud
club the thing about Crowder is and this
is a well known secret in the industry
HIDA monetizes his own videos to sell
more mugs who told you that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
idle hips idle hips we need an idea let
me get my iPad away from the water that
came out of the mug there eh
we're just didn't Izzy has took this
this week it's been a it's been a big
week we have a lot to talk about we have
some great guests today we have Paul
Joseph Watson on the show boom boom
prison planet Infowars he's probably out
of a job soon so maybe you'll see him
here we have the great one Mark Levin
here pretty happy about that and before
we get to the guest that we have here in
studio and the topic we'll be talking
about today of course social media the
tech giant's the D platforming and now
we're gonna have my lawyer actually
half-asian lawyer bill Richman to talk
about that let me ask you question of
the day social media giants obviously
they've started another round of purges
against figures as they see it being on
the far right or as we know it just not
the far left the question is now that
now we're beyond Alex Jones where's the
line do you think they have a line do
you have a line and what actions do you
think should be taken against these
leviathans if any when it comes to
YouTube Twitter Facebook and I'm all wet
I have two fixes what else do the dance
firm Dancing with those dancing too hard
look you can see this this is disgusting
alright producing of course first week
without knocking John same around every
now and then is a quarter black Garrett
you are a quarter black I am for sure
it's only a quarter yeah I can't do it
that good my friend got a Cuban cigar
that was so clearly faked on the label
it was misspelled that was the
equivalent to that in a hood pass a huge
pianist huge pianist calm own Benjamin
is in third share with us today how are
you own it's great to be back I now
realize I do have to go the shirt store
yeah because I showed up and now I
realize that I'm wearing a similar
there's be twins you have dates coming
up in Houston right I do I got dates all
over got a huge pianist calm to check it
out and get my last specials yes there
are a lot of speaking this fing this
week knows a special guy who's but I
think we have here G Morgan Judah the
one he's buying wine today so he'll be
back next Monday but he's gone so my
half-asian whatever bill Richman is in
the studio are you really glad to baby
we're gonna be talking about Facebook
and Twitter yeah you know what I we're
helping to fix the world so it's a
better world for him to live I'm pretty
sure that I'm pretty sure Skynet will
have fallen by that I wouldn't worry
about it in other news let's get to this
first 20:18 news I should say Christine
Hall Quist could be elected the first
ever transgender Governor on Tuesday she
won the Democrat primary victim in the
first tray now this is by the way in
Vermont so whoever wins a Democrat prime
very likely to win the general and this
is prompted Vermont's own Ben and Jays
to release a string of new inspired
flavors actually quite a few so this
brings us to this week's Crowder 7+1
that's right Ben and Jerry's top seven
transgender themed items I know by the
way there are there are Republicans
elected in Vermont I know even as
governor but this is in this case in a
primary you need one that's gonna be a
size 12 shoe she is a size bill coming
in hot
he didn't know if he should say that one
what is wrong with you offer you're the
biggest stars in the world respectful if
I had written that joke I would have
stood up to deliver it yes I would have
been very proud of that I am standing up
and yet I'm still shorter than like your
father did SMU law graduation but your
mom stayed seated because she was
disappointed you weren't a doctor yes
yes and she remained seated to this day
disappointed did you know that it's
actually true what's that he has a tiger
mom and she wishes he were a doctor
being in like an awesome half-asian
lawyer isn't good enough no no not at
all no no whoa my mom's just really
happy I have a driver's license I have a
class-c license did your head as an
actor like you got hit you're Class C
for motorcycle it's a huge deal I won't
write I won't ride a motorcycle at six
seven it's probably not very prudent to
do it be like that Dumbo all right
listen number seven Ben and Jerry's top
[ __ ] flavored ice creams a little on
the nose
chunky train number six Adam's apple
crisp I see what you did that doesn't
even sound very appetizing
I don't think any of these do because we
go to number five chocolate chip cookie
ooh yeah and then we've got number four
triple caramel hormone blockers yes yes
but only between the ages of nine and 11
if you listen to Julie Ray yesterday
according the dsm-5 you only administer
though is between nine and eleven
because that's the cautious approach
they can just reverse it and undo the
puberty blockers if they want to
continue as opposed to say not
administering radical hormone blocking
therapy I don't know number three mint
chocolate abnormally high suicide rate
which doesn't really seem like a flavor
that's it terrible flavor I think you
wanted AI you wanted this one you wanted
to have a crack at number two Harry
Baals SIA
admits it so much for what he deliver
look look at my eyes let alone the
audience that's intense and actually
number one was actually this was similar
to number but you know what this was
Owens in it this was Owens baby he's
pretty proud of it number one Ben and
Jerry transgender seemed ice cream Owen
Benjamin that would be the strawberry
short lifespan that's true that's we're
gonna hit letters everybody with a plus
one banana split then invert it into
your body cavity make a fake vagina
that's been this week seven plus one
that doesn't sound appetizing at all in
other news that that sucks New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo told an audience
that quote America was never that great
remember there was a point when we were
in general elections and Democrats had
to act as though they didn't hate their
country yeah that was before that
bug-eyed lady yes it was before it was
that's the Pug eyed lady the pug ID law
guide lady we talked about Nina and Nina
Pinta Santa Maria Cortez yes that lady
can you remember her exact Alexandria
Acacio Cortes there you go ooh would you
have known that bill no no I would not
have gotten that correct at all and
that's why your mother's disappointed in
you 17,000 reason he missed the bumper
multiculturalism
he's so racist I didn't believe us we
have a clip we're not gonna make America
great again it was over that great why
did he sound like the guy in dumb and
Dumberer is like there are other people
who need to use the found that guy
sounds like rarity was Ray Romano's
brother and I just I just can't believe
that these are actual people but his
brother actually for those I don't know
CNN's Chris Cuomo was overheard as
saying hello darkness miles
I thought it was pretty great I've come
that's pretty childish but it was we
just wanted to fit it in there because
he's a DNC pool boy I feel like the
Cuomo brothers are such AI buzzkills
they could be sitting in a hot tub with
champagne and they're just like I heard
bubbles they're too fizzy my name is
Neil
have you seen piglet anyway he has an
English accent I don't know how to do
accents so I just run in got the Cuomo's
that is decidedly too new yorky I'm in
for New Yorker even New Yorkers Blake
okay listen can you tone it down a
little bit yeah they're like we're not a
parody of ourselves from a 50s mobster
movie listen stop getting work club
you're not that fantastic who likes do
you think people are still voting for
the Cuomo's people we're gonna vote for
Anthony Weiner until you became more
Anthony Weiner do you realize only after
the first scandal people are talking
about form yeah cos New York has
Stockholm Syndrome that's a good point
oh it's almost are also making it so
felons can vote I want they're getting
all there they're hedging their bets so
you get to break all of the laws yep
vote on them exactly speaking of
bringing once finally a congressman
actually wants to know if the Chinese
spy staffed by Dianne Feinstein
compromised classified Intel this comes
from the Washington Examiner Congressman
Jim banks he asked we all while we all
know that the FBI approached senator
Feinstein's five years ago to informer
of this threat right now there are more
questions than ever regarding this case
I'm just wondering how the spy got away
with this for so long
it really does seem remarkable it was
right underneath Feinstein's eye
yeah Feinstein's not good at figuring
out who's spying on her I do not say it
seems to be one of our weeks but all
this and we've been talking about the
Russians that we've taken our eye off
the Chinese and they're so
passive-aggressive paper straws well
they continue with that last you know
that comes from them all of the modern
inconveniences it's clear where it's
coming from
pretty good pretty good big strong
congressman I think a copy boy this is
what you like it and it's kind of try to
so you know there coffee on your chrome
yes
Thank You Ming's very thoughtful oh yeah
ah what is this weird paper thing what
is this an official bum down yeah I
remember that bill why would the outlaw
plastic straws
I don't know why I can't eat rent made
you guys bear I mean you're brave
environmentalist did dad you oh no you
you get coffee on your shirt kill you
must be sad I don't shy about that it
American it's like drinking through a
number-two pencil today how you know
your coffee
I got it enjoy what you like I know you
need caffeine no you get sleepy it's
good I still feel a little bit sleepy oh
you feel sleepy I'm so bummed out right
now that cab all [ __ ] it's okay now
there's an important vote today to keep
the internet free from censorship oh I
guess you don't need your iPad for you
yeah damn it oh no it's only in 87% oh
oh you know what no you know but I only
have charged enjoyed only don't judge
people away oh no awesome
yeah America yeah I wish I loved
anything as much as Owen loves watching
himself and scales over to you it wasn't
laughing at V I was just do it all you
like you're killing me that was also a
laugh and think about the fact bills mom
is probably like why aren't you also a
spy my mom's got enough disappointment
that she's even disappointed for that
spy not being a doctor by the way
quarterblack cared no one can we all
confirm that bill was laughing the
hardest in the room at that sketch while
it was playing yeah yeah bill was
laughing the hardest and Asian's capable
of laughing this is true hey this isn't
a spirit of crazy rich agents agents are
getting all kinds of screen time I love
this is absolutely no and whenever
someone says that's right you really do
have to blame Mickey Rooney it really
goes back to Breakfast at Tiffany's and
I it is remarkably racist but we'll
piggyback off of it okay to go back to
the question of earlier so
is something we're talking about today
and I do want to hear from you guys I
know
apparently aren't that many opinions I
hate to say it it's not that it's not
that we live in a monolith but it's
everyone who's not a far left
progressive pretty much lives in a
monolith you're protecting freedom of
speech so Alex Jones obviously was
simultaneously remove from Facebook
YouTube Apple so on okay move
unfortunately a lot on the Left rejoiced
now we talked about that last week and I
think I know you weren't here when we
talked about that but obviously you know
about the story but things have changed
so now stefan molyneux his youtube
channel or see to hard strike seemingly
out of the blue we don't know what for
yet then youtube issued the the h3h3
productions a hard strike I think they
were blocked from streaming right yeah
block follow they were streaming well
what happened while they were streaming
yeah
and I think a big part of that was
because they addressed the Jones
conspiracy I have to say allegedly right
that covers me right well yes I say
allegedly I mean apparently because
YouTube said it was a mistake Edward but
the stream was taken down because they
addressed the Alex Jones story now let's
not forget since we last spoke yeah
McGinnis spontaneously banned from
Twitter who's next who's now who's next
well here's the thing social justice for
his claim or at least we should say they
they hope this comes from inverse that
we're next did you see this no Aayla
they actually they called me all right
into the three alt right jail and Julie
borovsky she's the token libertarian
chick that's her search channels name
she couldn't be less Pro Trump on the
conservative side insane it's so funny
with him it's funny when they are when
they call people like us all right
because the alt-right is way more
similar to the left they both think
white males are super special they just
differ on policy yes it's like a circle
it's like a circle it comes from like
here and then it comes back around right
here exactly how about the fact that
they accused hi Alex Jones of being
conspiracy theorist and then the biggest
companies in the world conspired to get
rid of it yes exactly
all right that's right you're all right
listen short if possible well the short
of absolutely ben shapiro i have been
the most outspoken critic of the
alt-right in modern conservatism and
that's only because he's really jewish
you can't out shapiro shapiro okay i
mean i can't i can't get as personal
with the alt-right of shapiro because
i'll be honest I've never walked a mile
in a size 6 shoes i possibly know
I've never want to had that small I
don't know what all right means I well
that's the whole point it's an umbrella
term so in case by the way there were
still any doubt as to the veracity of
these claims from inverse they spelled
my name with a pH so not exactly
Pulitzer winning research department
they're high in verse but little fact
rate it is mostly true so there's that
now the claim is is not that Alex Jones
the conspiracy theorist accusing
congressman of being pot-bellied
interdimensional them interdimensional
vampires would explain Chuck Schumer
they used the worst excuse possible and
Bill well that's why I wanted to have
you here today because you can talk
about this and offer some insight the
social media platforms didn't say it was
about Sandy Hook it wasn't about the
conspiracy theories they just use this
chilling defense Jones violated the hate
speech policies if any of you read
YouTube's pop have you read YouTube or
Twitter's hate speech policies I have
not I just accept and move just accept
and move on I checked the box and I just
go well the thing is some of their hate
speech policies aren't consistent with
other hate speech policies for example
if you just sign up and you create an
account and then you have when you
become a partner so there we've had to
go through these quite a few times and
sometimes the same company will have
different explanations but this is
actually taken directly I think from
Google support bill my half-asian one
hour bill Richmond I think you can read
this right yeah absolutely
it's it's pretty clear right there in
the paragraph there is a fine line
between what is and what is not
considered to be eight speech for
instance it is generally okay to
criticize a nation state but if the
primary purpose of the content is to
incite hatred against a group of people
solely based on their ethnicity or if
the content promotes violence based on
any of these core attributes like
religion it violates our policy well I
want to get into first off you pointed
out something right before the show I
did I did the paragraph right before
this and I really encourage everyone to
go take a look at the actual policy yeah
because just above the paragraph I just
read is a sentence that says primary
purpose of inciting hatred against
individuals or groups based on certain
attributes such as race religion
disability etc but what you'll skip over
if you don't recognize the language that
the lawyerly language is the such as
they're not saying that this is the
exclusive list right it can be used to
ban people from the platform's or take
away their monetization or take away
their livelihood
it's
just an example so in fact when you read
the literal language of the hate speech
policy it is any characteristic that
YouTube decides or Google decides on a
certain day that applies to an
individual or group that they happen to
fancy at that time and I don't think
there's a real question about which ones
they fancy and which ones they don't
yeah I feel like they've weaponized
balls just retract into your body cavity
mine did
Oh terrifying that is well it's
weaponized opinions yeah it's it's kind
of like saying mustard is a hate
condiment yes and someone being like
what does that mean it's like I hate it
so it's gone now and the relish is
clearly all trite
it's just umbrella labels hate yeah and
by the way this isn't even true now that
legal leaves that you got into super
super important because it's like when
someone says uh the Bible says the
world's gonna end in October 12th what
where does it say I believe it's
somewhere near the back another second
there's a clause in there that's what
you have in a lot of I mean there are so
many outs with with contracts like these
kept and then and everyone out there
who's signing up for a YouTube channel
you'll become a YouTube partner please
please have a lawyer look it over
because a lot of people don't know what
they're signing into but even then
they're it's not true in the application
from YouTube because people have been
banned for hate speech simply for
criticizing nations or ideologies of
course too loose definition the
application of course of hate speech
it's some of the we've harped on here
for a long time it was one of the first
ever change my minds for those who
missed it yeah that was one way to do it
a sandwich board because it wasn't it
was in the state that's going to have a
new newly appointed [ __ ] governor and
we couldn't actually get permission to
be on their insured street but even back
then people were dumbfounded as to why
it could be against hate speech laws you
see that a lot on campus and let me
explain it to you in a way that maybe
you haven't heard I'm against hate
speech laws for the same reason I'm
against Washington DC's idea of
common-sense gun control now why am i
against that
okay I'll point you to exhibit a there
have been temporary Perry's barriers put
in place in many of the bridges across
London actually we're doing things like
designing out the possibility of a
hostile vehicle smash it into
pedestrians or builders now I know you
can say that wasn't Washington DC that's
not the point
so yeah after the London terror attack
the Mayor of London is implementing
vehicle control that's insane right now
we have the Straub and probably because
someone killed a guy with the straw
right
no I don't think it's the
passive-aggressive Asian I blame your
people we used to bring this up as an
extreme example to make a point on this
very show people would accuse us of
straw Manning well ha second it's way
more a 16 year old with a learner's
permit and a phone or using Google Maps
and she's Tech that's far more dangerous
than my ppq here in the desc but it
hasn't hurt a fly people say oh that's
silly no I'm like what do you want
vehicle control do you want to control
Jeep Cherokees alright now you're struck
no this is what they're actually want to
do in London it's actually happening
yeah satire becomes real life in about
three months well this is it what I just
spoke with Julie ray yesterday if you
didn't see the debate and we're talking
on hormone blockers and she said on
ironically well I'm gonna go buy that
dsm-5 by the guidelines I think should
the stage two guidelines which is a nine
to eleven years old is agreed upon by
all the major Medical Association's all
the major Medical Association's agree
that you should put nine to eleven year
olds on hormone blockers does that
include the American Dental Association
I don't know what her definitions are
here comes if II know that that's child
abuse that's the thing that got me
banned from Twitter and YouTube in the
same day but it happened to me so early
that no one really noticed I was kind of
like the Sex Pistols of this banning
situation actually you know it's
interesting you bring that because you
don't know how I met Bill yeah how did
you meet bill no I met bill the I was
actually in Michigan and so what
happened was remember there was an
article was it was it Engadget I think
it was it was not wired but it was one
of the yeah like Engadget or Mashable
yeah so there was an article out that
said okay Facebook actually they do have
people controlling what goes into your
feet it's not just algorithmic yeah and
there was just a list released publicly
and it included the Ted Cruz for
president I think the Chris Kyle
foundation Breitbart and steven crowder
it was was on the list and they released
the documents and I called my friend our
good friend Jordan and I asked him I
said hey do you know it could you help
me they say you know different kind of
literally a business word does this kind
of stuff my friend bills pretty good he
sounds like Seth Rogen it's exact you
know that's literally and put me in
touch with Bill do you member I called
you I said I want you to take a look at
this and just okay let me take a look at
and I'll call you back
and he called me back in about ten
minutes and you said yeah this is pretty
bad
I mean you were on that list and it was
clear I mean it you know for those who
haven't taken a look at the article I
mean you got to go back and take a look
at how clear it was uh a former employee
came out and said did you know we have a
black list with these people's names on
it so that we can keep them from coming
to the top because the insinuation being
they otherwise would have been at the
top of the feeds and the lists and the
other any other public lists we have
suspected it along this is the thing
right it makes it if you accuse people
of being conspiratorial and you conspire
against them like you said yeah of
course all of a sudden that little ember
becomes a flame and we always thought
man it's really weird we used to trend a
lot on Facebook quite a bit and now
we've had videos we've had articles that
get far more shares that get far more
interactions and algorithmically it
seems like this should trend because
it's two or three times this popped was
a thing that did trend huh I think you
said no no it's the algorithms until
this list came out and I guess we can
talk about a lot but they basically got
settled we worked it out we we worked it
out your mom she's Facebook your mom
should be real proud of that you worked
it out but you could you know you could
have been operating on people and saving
their lives though yeah you could have
been that useful
could've been a Ben Carson so but my
point is that when you give Washington
the authority to determine common-sense
gun control well guess what you give
them all guns before we're talking about
London in car control not just ar-15s
not just the awesome Walther PPQ at the
best striker-fired trigger in existence
nice little plug there but the right to
private firearm ownership period look at
Heller versus DC because you gave the
authority to the government in the first
place well now here comes knife control
now here comes vehicle control same
thing when people talk about this fiscal
it's not just guns it's not just free
speech it's the same thing when you give
them complete control over your paycheck
it's why don't we need to take from we
need to take from the 1% that's ok we'll
take from the 1% when you read
socialized healthcare then three years
down the line you look like Venezuela
just give it all to me you filthy - shut
up a [ __ ] that's what happens you give
them a foothold and they get in they
they get their foot in the door they're
there all the way give any bureaucratic
organism be at Washington or the tech
giant's in this case the ability to
determine hate speech and you give up
all speech and that's just the basic
philosophy of delegating your rights to
another entity not even taking into
account these kinds of policies would
have to be carried out
with total reliability and efficiency
right now we're just talking about the
flat we're just all about the moral
aspect of this but let me get to the
pragmatic aspect you have to believe for
you to line up with them you have to
believe they can carry this out
efficiently you think so you guys think
so
know anyone anyone told you Alert ruler
I have no idea why no no what you know
how I know because they accidentally
banned Robin Williams who's been dead
for four years geez that was a part of
this last purge that's insane you know a
criminal from beyond the grave you know
I don't know a whole lot but I know Jack
Dorsey is a tiny prick look at that man
big ego small penis Oh what an [ __ ]
right sad eyes sad eyes but funny face
that's Robin Williams just sad eyes
where the funnies telling jokes but he's
always said I can't watch his movies
anymore it is your fault jack it is your
fault it is your fault listen to me son
all this I told your fault yeah yeah I
know but it's all good it's no check you
don't know son look at me it's all your
fault yeah yeah you said that
seriously you a little prick okay Alex
Jones I didn't get to that dramatic
scene what's the no no I would have
sucked at it anyway go I know you wanted
to cry did you want to cry in the
student was building it up man I was
building up I was about to do a
full-blown scene like Meryl Streep style
well I think you and I were talking
about this this week it's important for
people to know that Alex Jones may say
some things that you you don't like that
maybe you don't that I don't like we
don't like personally but being banned
from YouTube Twitter Facebook out
Spotify iTunes all at once it cannot
happen without collusion and Jack Dorsey
Bible we're talking about him here he is
bragging that he was wielding the power
of his platform to change
Alex's behavior and his points of view
here you go see the clip well I feel you
know any any suspension whether it be a
permanent one or a temporary one make
someone think about their actions and
their behaviors we we have found that it
does have the potential to change impact
and change behavior there you go he's
basically saying we put him in a timeout
to try and make sure that he agrees with
us by the way when did he join Mumford &
Sons I have no idea
yeah and that doesn't work with grown
man what's he gonna have him like on a
chalkboard say the frogs are not gay the
frogs are not gay that like like Alex
Jones in short of The Simpsons yeah and
what he doesn't understand his penis a
certain type of person and I think I may
actually fall in this category is when
you do something like that
you do the opposite like if someone like
Jack Dorsey does that to me like oh you
can't say this word that's the only word
I'll say for the next 10 years yeah
that's turned out to be a problem for
you it has I've lost a lot so I'm bad
call sometimes sometimes it works
sometimes it works great
sometimes it's one gonna miss yeah
that's all of us who've been sitting in
this chair but the point that really
bothers me about that clip is he's
talking about punishing someone to to
change behavior that he doesn't like no
I mean while this was trending all day
today hundreds of left-wing papers
they've been publishing these anti-trump
screeds demanding that President Donald
Trump stop attacking the press all right
this is what they've been talking about
he's attacking the press because of
libel laws and he really here's the
thing these bannings of alt right or
even the left-leaning voices it's it's
clearly about leftist media and tech
giant's coordinating together an effort
to silence anyone questioning their
narrative and they're completely
systematically shutting down anyone just
take your take your pick
take your pick of anyone who doesn't
live in Silicon Valley no they're not
welcome okay so this simultaneous
systematic deep platforming it like I
said it can't happen without collusion
the statistical likelihood is virtually
impossible almost unheard of and the
left couldn't care less about it that's
why I'm making me to go when the papers
are saying hey free posh tag Free Press
really is that what you care about
because right now this is happening not
a word
nothing and I'm curious to know if the
collusion was happening if like Yahoo is
trying to get in and they're like get
out of here Yahoo no I can better people
to and they're like get out of here
Yahoo we're hanging out with suck web
crawlers like this is my opportunity
Alta Vista pops a nice oh come on the
bentback paper clip Ask Jeeves is like
all Birnam you misspelled hate speech
with a paper clip whatever happened that
guy I don't know was it was it called
lippy and their lippy clippy's was a
purple gorilla for a while
nobody could be was never helpful no it
was never helpful at all it just
suggested things that you weren't in any
way searching for at all yeah they're
like do you want to know how to restart
your computer I'm like I know that
Clippy is this is this is this
conspiratorial of me whole room let me
know yeah well I'm asking you bill I'm
asking you own this is happening right
before midterm elections is it just that
means it's just me you let me know in
the comment may know it means motive and
opportunity Matt like it that's where my
conspiracies hit it's like means motive
opportunity and all of those things
check and they're very very capable of
it yeah what do you think bill I think
when you look at a lawyer right now
allegedly I'll be straight about it when
you when you look at what who has the
the amount to gain how they can exercise
the power to achieve that game yeah and
the timing of doing the thing that would
help them with that gain it's hard to
say any other conclusion other than
collusion we're lucky there's a lot of
gains in there but they get followed but
they're so bad at human nature they
don't realize it'll backfire like now
I'm definitely voting them and I'll have
three watches lots of alarms ringing
make sure that you don't yeah it'll look
like seenin hook when doesn't often
wakes up in his night exactly this is a
big reason what we have half-asian a
lawyer billers when you're on retainer
this is why we have mud clip I'll talk
more about where we're headed after a
guests in the clothes but the fight
right now is it is right here and I just
want to make something really quick this
is absolutely the hill that I'm willing
to die on yeah absolutely
well you know we'll talk about that more
in the closing I think we'll talk about
it quite a bit with Paul Joseph Watson
because we have one more story for you
resident favorite non-lesbian who were
not entirely convinced of Lena Dunham
posed nude to commemorate the nine-month
anniversary of her hysterectomy as one
does it's come from Fox News I've never
celebrated the nine-month anniversary of
anything
well why start now she posed nude in
quarterblack Garrett can you bring up
that photo for us yeah yeah give me one
second I think we have the picture here
of course left to blur it for on-air
those on radio oh god podcast and mute
oh god let's go okay what
I'll come back after this that Michael
[Music]
this town ain't big enough for the two
of us actually as a matter of fact
geographically there is physical room
for I've had enough of yours bestest
Leighton smug talk fill your tumbler you
son of a ladder with Crowder studios
protected exclusively by Walter and
hopper
[Music]
[Music]
all right Greg glad to have our first
guest here in the program he's right at
the center of all this of all the
controversy with YouTube and obviously
there's Infowars knew he's worked with
Alex Jones you know him you love him on
the YouTube at prison planet is what I
believe it is I know it's at prison
planet on Twitter did it have the
YouTube channel right there Paul Joseph
Watson yeah you just google my name Paul
Joseph Watson it's basically that
YouTube you're a cocky Englishman you
come on here looking all half-asleep and
sexy and just go home everywhere pretty
much that was probably wrong right there
was probably Liverpool or something and
grossly offensive I apologize it's not
very good before we get into the big
tech all the censorship stuff you had a
great video this week the age of
emotional incontinence and you're
talking about privilege guilt the
emotions of people always needing to be
expressed in the highest profile way
possible explain for people who've
missed it again it's a prison planet on
YouTube but you can fill them in in case
you know they can't be bothered to go to
click it hurts yeah god forbid 10
minutes Plus video but yeah it's
basically based on theories written by
Theodore Dalrymple who's a British
writer who know it's the change
especially in Britain over the past
10-15 years this cult of emotional
sentimentality where we're not only you
know expected we're encouraged to over
express to over emote over absolutely
everything which is the point I make in
the video you know it's actually
encouraging the form of mental illness
called Moodle ability which is where you
overreact emotionally to everything and
we see in reality TV we see it with you
know whenever a celebrity dies they're
canonized we have to go through this
this public ritual of the emoting and
crying over them even though if we'd
weren't really into them didn't really
know much about them before they died
now we have to do it so yeah it's based
on Theodore Dalrymple's writings it's
called the age of emotional incontinence
it's quite in-depth but it's up on
YouTube for now it's a pendulum swing -
right it's going too far the other way
and that's a big thing because they say
well the toxic masculinity tells a lot
of young people particularly young men
they can't discuss their emotions at all
they're not allowed to be emotionally
communicative at all which isn't true
that's not what we believe we just
believe that you know young men
shouldn't cry at the drop of a hat
there's a time to cry there's a time to
express your emotions and there's a
time to act based on logic and so I
think they use this drama and a lot of
the time to to build up what we now see
a culture of all of my emotions are just
as valid as everybody else's emotions at
all times and it makes me want to stab
myself well it's this whole thing and I
mention this in the video when people
say there's a stigma around depression
there's a stigma around talking about
your feelings no there isn't that's all
anyone does at this point you go through
YouTube and type in depression there's
there's a million and more videos about
it the more we talk about depression
this is the point I make the more
depressed people become and obviously
that's because of a number of factors
but this over emoting about it
constantly over sharing doesn't seem to
be having the desired solution of making
people less depressed and obviously I
differentiate between people with PTSD
you know war veterans or female rape
victims I'm talking about I mean I give
examples of people who cry because they
can't get their eyebrows to look the
same they had a big twitter thing last
year what makes you cry and it was
literally that it was literally oh I
tried to fit too many things in my bag
and I can't so I started I ever visited
the threading kiosk at the mall I take
it it's very pain yes so it's about it's
about the whole range of human emotions
being cheap and people not having the
capacity to deal with real trauma
because they flip off the switch at a
moment's notice and anything triggers
them but it as threading is very painful
especially if it is all for naught I'd
probably be upset I think it's an
important differentiation to make that
you are making and that's also why you
know we've had these videos where we did
the the sting I guess he would say
undercover in the college socialists and
the girl says well because I have PTSD I
don't remember what else she was talking
about obviously I was going oh wait hold
on a second there there's a hook PTSD
and I said oh I'm so sorry
do you want to talk about shoes that's a
very rude question so they found out she
was writing about it everywhere anyway
so I asked a question that I could have
already found out the answer to what the
quick little thumb press well it goes
back to they want to control reality by
controlling the language if your words
harm them physically which is the
argument they now have tried to make the
words of violence then they can shut you
up they can silence you so it all goes
back once again to control and power
that's but the only reason why they do
any of this and that's laid out of the
video I mean we got like emotional
support pigs on planes at this point
we've got people there was not
recently a couple who had 400 different
personalities that they slipped into
from day to day some of which were
children so they couldn't take care of
themselves and society's normalizing
this because the gamut the range of
mental illnesses that were being told to
accept as you know forms of oppression
if you even disagree or question them is
getting ever vaster ever wider and it's
basically normalizing mental illness
when it should be a stigma to some
extent if it's been over prescribed and
if people are over emoting at nothing I
remember when the temporary insanity
plea became really in vogue and people
were looking into it saying is that is
that a real thing like well you know I
was crazy when I killed him but I think
I'm fixed now and now they're saying
like well you know I I was able to feed
myself until I reverted to Timmy my
childlike self and now I need you to
wipe my ass please speaking of control
and power obviously listen you you've
worked with Alex Jones for a long time
there's been this deep platforming we
were just talking about it and we've
just by inverse I think it's a magazine
and online website we've just been with
yours truly number one most likely all
right channel as they put it Stephen
with a pH to be removed from YouTube
well you know what are your thoughts in
this because we've talked about this
obviously a private business can do what
they want if they're honest about it but
to me what's so crazy is all of these
different platforms at once that can't
happen without collusion well exactly
and it came out in the New York Times
about Tim Cook and Zuckerberg personally
made the decision to pull Infowars but
you've got a look at the back story to
illustrate how this is not all just a
private company we had Democrat
congressman in October last year when
the truck attack happened in New York
talking to Twitter executives saying why
is this Paul Joseph Watson's tweet about
the truck attacking top trending on the
hashtag and the Twitter executive was
immediately like yeah we saw that we
removed that last month
congressman Deutsche Democrat you know
grilling YouTube and Facebook executives
why haven't you banned Alex Jones why
haven't you banned Infowars boom a month
later it happens this is also a lobbying
campaign as he said CNN Oliver Darcy
have been lobbying for six solid months
to get Infowars removed from YouTube
Facebook etc it wasn't addressing wasn't
horrid I see from the blaze
or am I mistaken yeah he's a
self-proclaimed conservative and he's
the one leading the charge and this is
how it works
they're in communication constantly with
big tech with Twitter Facebook yeah CNN
so they're constantly oh what about this
tweet doesn't this violate what about
this to it and it's every single day
they put it on Twitter then you get the
brigade inge you get the which on mob
outrage crew to pile on and that's how
they do it so it's not just these
companies enforcing their Terms of
Service this is a lobbying campaign
it's abrogating campaign and now as you
said there's a Newsweek article today
about me saying oh why hasn't he been
banned now so I'm not gonna lie that was
my question oh did you I just wasn't
asking it so hopefully but I thought oh
is Paul gonna be gone but here you are
well give it time well I mean I mean I I
do wonder what they obviously you've got
to be on their list do you think that
they all know who alex jones is
therefore they would all know your
connection with Infowars and prison
planet or do you think they're so
ignorant they're just taking their
marching orders that most people
wouldn't really have a clue because you
obviously are more moderate you're not
as conspiratorial you're more
libertarian I know we've talked about
this and you're close with Alex and I
don't want you know listen I don't want
to speak about anyone who's not here but
you you certainly would be seen as less
inflammatory than Alex himself well I
mean people have asked me about this
about you know the comments yesterday
where it didn't you know the Twitter
suspension about the battle rifles and
all that which I they stripped out the
context by the way at the start the rant
he was talking politically legally
judicially they strip now but yeah I
haven't violated any of their Terms of
Service trying to control Alex Jones's
language on a three-hour radio show is
like telling a grizzly bear not to
behave like a grizzly bear so yes if you
drill down and go through pick through
every single sentence you're gonna find
something that might violate their TOS
right again it's these brigades it's the
fact that Media Matters writes an
article about this three hours later
he's suspended by Twitter okay that's
not just a private company going about
its business that's abrogating campaign
that's a media pressure campaign which
is why it's so ridiculous today they're
all whining about Oh Trump's a fascist
because he's silencing the media
meanwhile they've been lobbying for six
months to silence actual media outlets
we're the ones being silenced what is
Trump doing to
apart from calling me names Jesus words
right out of my mouth we just talked
about that and I couldn't agree with you
more aside from tweets and listen III do
get uncomfortable any president starts
trying to expand libel laws as it
applies to journalism he hasn't done it
he's talked about it I'm glad he's not
doing that right now but if you look at
like you said the policies that come
from the progressive left if you look at
what the what actions they are taking
they could not care less about freedom
and journalism well what what do you
think actually happens the genuine
question I do think there can be some
self correction here in the market with
YouTube because they lose all of their
viewers if they do this and that's
YouTube's only capital as their viewers
people who are actually on their website
do you think because of the backlash now
because of what happened with 8th Street
at age three three production that's a
horrible name really difficult to say do
you think maybe they backtrack they step
it backward you just think they go
forward full-throttle well we've seen it
in the past where we've had it really
bad with the D monetization with the
whole SPLC you know flagging content
that got pretty bad for a while then
they stepped it back but again it's
these brigades if these brigades of blue
checkmarks on Twitter pile on which they
do every day
then you've got people within these
companies who feel pressured the thing
that's different about Twitter from what
I know Jack actually to some extent
supports free speech believe it or not
he's like the least worst of them
because he's talked to big conservative
people who've been to dinner with him
and he's getting pressured from within
his own company from all these history I
thought he was the worst I thought he
was the worst of the three he was about
a year and a half ago and I thought
Susan Wojcicki still had to be beholden
to it you know to took the hook to the
bottom dollar at a certain point but
maybe not maybe not since we had Clint
Howard player and a Christmas Carol
she's a little upset as I said with
YouTube this talk and I think there was
something like this before but it's not
really gone anywhere over YouTube is
Union where all the big creators in
unison complain if something really bad
happens and I've been talking to some
pretty big YouTube people you might have
a guess who they are and they're
interested in getting on board and
talked with me I'm not there we want you
on board obviously and there's this talk
of a big live stream with all the top
personalities probably next week
I think Breitbart setting that up so you
know
a White House petition maybe we can get
200,000 people to sign it well this is
why we have half agent lawyer bill
Richman who's in the restroom right now
on retainer because we know this is a
fight that we've seen coming for a long
while I think it's going to arrive at
our doorstep our doorstep mulattoes
Crowder sooner rather than later it will
arrive at some point and like I said
earlier and I'll talk about in the close
it's the hill I'm willing to die on
because we've invested so much not only
in the platform but on the people who we
talk with the people who we impact it's
about the impact that we have and and
it's important and I think that's why
they want to silence us
final question because you work
obviously alongside Infowars does how's
your job security are you good you need
us to PayPal you anything you okay well
actually product sales were up three
times over the past couple of weeks so
all this censorship does have some add
some you know decent knocking effects
obviously that's not gonna last long
term but you know the app was downloaded
millions of times and millions and
newsletter signups so we'll be all right
for now we got some capital and we've
got a loyal audience that will support
us in times of need and they have done
well I appreciate that your audience
says that now where's the best place for
people to find you work so they can
support you personally prison planet on
Twitter is the best place at prison
planet on Twitter as long as Jack Dorsey
still thinks he's cute and why wouldn't
he look at those baby blues and we're
the same way listen that's what we had
to create mug club because we're still
fighting the fight on YouTube and I
appreciate that you're there Paul Joseph
Watson you must go we have Mark Levin
next thanks a lot the kiss
that's weird my wife won't answer the
phone she told me to call her right now
oh no way usually you have a number in
your phone of course I do it's my wife
it's one digit off now
oh no she probably real marry you that's
a bummer just definitely annoying yeah
probably moving I don't know I jump I'm
sleeping on the couch masturbating no
why
[Music]
[Music]
all right let me have our next guest our
second guest in the program good friend
of the show he's he's obviously a good
friend of the show because he's also on
the CR TV network if you're a member of
Mudd Club you get his show there as well
it's a Mark Levin show calm he's all
over radio as well levin TV is the
program the great one mr. mark levin how
are you sir I'm good Steve how are you
oh okay I'm a little bit a little bit
tired a little bit tired of the news a
little bit tired of all of the things we
were just talking with Paul Joseph
Watson about this this Big D platforming
and I wanted to get your opinion on this
because I know listen there's no love
loss for you on a personal level with
you and Alex Jones as far as what you
would agree or disagree on but we've
seen a lot of people from across the
political spectrum say okay all right
this this is a really slippery slope
right now where do you line up on this
and do you think that at some point you
could be in the crosshairs
I don't know Alex Jones honestly I've
never listened Alex Jones I read about
Alex Jones and you know what that tells
me what harm is a guy doing he may be a
goofball he may be way out there he may
be a lot of things but it's like
anything else
you don't want to watch you don't watch
you don't want to listen you don't
listen you don't want to read about him
you don't read it but I'll tell you what
I'm sick of
I'm sick of modern-day book burning I'm
sick of taking statues down the people
don't like I'm sick of taking people off
the who you don't like and so forth and
so I'll tell you what else is amazing
the left is nuts
the mainstream left is nuts they're on
MSNBC CNN they have guests that say the
most outrageous things nobody talks
about taking them off the air and then
we have to hear about their protecting
free speech when they're not then we
have to hear they're protecting freedom
of the press when they're not so so many
crazy things are being said by so many
crazy people on so many platforms you
know I pick on one nut you can pick on a
whole lot of nuts so my attitude is let
it go yeah you can pick on all these
nuts I do think you know if you tell my
mainstream leftists a good example
because they said like you said you've
read about Alex Jones right well if you
read from the left about anybody you're
gonna get a slanted view and let's take
Alex Jones out of the equation but let's
take Cortes you know Nina Pinta Santa
Maria Cortez they're this current
democratic socialists she uh ben shapiro
called her out as he does for a debate
and she said that he was cat calling her
now if you were to
the article from the left you believe
that Ben Shapiro is some kind of a
hoodlum cat calling a potential DNC
candidate that's not accurate so then
what does that do it leads us down the
trail to maybe D platforming ben shapiro
they call him alt right they call myself
alright that really is my concern here
because they use the same tactics
against everyone and that can be turned
on either of us yeah now joy reid was
never d platformed was she and the
things that she said how about the kook
that now writes for the editorial page
of the new york times with this hideous
outrageous poisonous language about
white men and whites this and whites
that you know she got a promotion so by
that you know alex jones should be
writing for the new york times editorial
board yeah i think it makes about as
much sense and we were talking earlier
in the break but Omarosa and i mean I'm
getting although I'm thinking Ponderosa
steakhouse at although no hungry
although if you hear Ponderosa
steakhouse and you're hungry you needed
to Lorient because I don't think there
are any more any more of those Bob steak
what do you make of this you know it's
always these things get so convoluted
stories like stormy Daniels now
apparently might run for office you just
go okay these things seem so politically
motivated it's hard to really sort of
piecemeal this into the truth what's
been your take on this situation I know
it's died down a little bit but Monday
it was the most important story of of
the year apparently I take on this is
how we dumbed down America I mean
honestly
nobody cares about Omarosa Ponderosa
stormy Daniels nobody cares about any of
this stuff but these are puppets for the
media to use to attack Trump that's what
it's all about right
Omarosa was hated by the left all of a
sudden they love her it's like Jim Comey
they wanted him fired
Trump fires him all of a sudden he's an
angel and we got to use Jim Comey yeah I
think the problem here kind of goes back
to the deep platforming you and I most
of your viewers most of mine believe in
freedom of the press we believe in the
First Amendment and freedom of speech
that's great and then the media says if
you attack them you're attacking freedom
of the press no we're not attacking
freedom of the press who is attacking
freedom of the press we couldn't shut
down the press if we wanted to no we're
attacking the knuckleheads we're
attacking the fact that they have
degraded what press means right we're
attacking those one ideological bent
pretty much in the media we're attacking
the fact that there's so many important
things going on in the world and they
bring in porn stars and their goofball
lawyers and they bring in Omarosa though
I find it so funny to hear the great one
Mark Levin said the word porn starts
porn stars I don't know it just there's
something I never thought I heard that
right
I would never it'd be like but you know
Bernie Sanders uttering fiscal
responsibility you don't expect it but
no I think you're right here let me let
me kind of pause this one thing imagine
on the flip side the left absolutely has
the ability to completely eliminate
right-wing press they completely have
the ability to silence us if not for the
internet and if not of course for now
social media which eventually will
bypass and that's why they're like a
baby being put in its crib throwing a
temper tantrum before naptime
they did have a very important point now
that's a very important point you know
it every five years or so they take a
run at the conservative talk radio and
try and put that out of brightness try
and create fairness you know it's always
the iron fist is always hidden behind
fairness and reform you had a memo
circulating by Mark Warner he's the
senior Tourette's senator from the state
of Virginia may notice and this guy he's
talking puts a memo out by basically how
to nationalize the Internet they always
want to nationalize stuff on behalf of
freedom and equity right so they're the
ones attacking the internet they're the
ones who attack talk radio they're the
ones who attack Fox do you know any
serious conservative who wants to shut
down any media platform or who wants to
nationalize the Internet I can't think
of any no I you know and I don't think
that we'd really want to shut down any
media because we more so just want to
watch them suffer yeah we have a lot of
ideas and we want to get them out and we
want to get them out to as many people
as we possibly can yeah that's why
you're as big as you are and some others
are as big as they are the reason is we
like ideas we like to engage no I think
you're absolutely right and that's not
you know I've grown up I had the pirate
talk radio because lunch I was in
Montreal we didn't really have it so I
had to pirate it across from Plattsburgh
New York I've talked about that because
we had government run media exclusively
back then and a lot of people not
realize that I said no you need
go to Venezuela basically picture NPR
times a million and it was our only news
source for the longest time yeah it
really is
fine chillingly scary when you think of
what's going on right now because I hear
the left a lot you know they talked
about cool Parisians meaning and the
government man and listen I understand
listen there's crony capitalism
absolutely but to say that corporations
are an arm of the government and they're
doing censorship on behalf of the
government going oh hold on a second we
think all of social media is censoring
Alex Jones for Donald Trump but if the
shoes on the other foot
imagine Hillary Clinton in office right
now corporations are really run by
conservatives very very few very few
that they hate corporations that are in
you know do things like make it possible
to be warm during the winter and and
cooler during the summer we call those
oil companies you know they hate
companies like that because that's just
who they are but most corporations are
not run by conservatives most CEOs are
not conservative in fact most
billionaires aren't even conservative
some are most are not and so they talk
about like there's this cabal of
corporations that are out to get the
little guy no it's actually big
centralized iron-fisted autocratic
government that's out to get the little
guy well I think it's a good point is
there's a stark contrast because people
can look at this people can look at the
statistics for small and mid-sized
businesses most of those business owners
are conservative but when you get to a
certain point where you're effectively a
lobbying group and a lot of big
businesses are you learn how to play
ball and you end up at least installing
as CEO some people who know how to play
political football and that's kind of
what you see with a lot of these big
corporations not the same for mid in
upstart businesses all right we do have
to get we can't can't talk for that long
and I know you're tired and I'm tired
we've only had long weeks you know
fiscal responsibility oh my god stormy I
like she's very buzzed at me at Mark
Levin show Levin TV on CR TV is there
anything anywhere else where people can
support you it's a great one yes my bank
accounts available right now there's a
rush in watching this going I will get
lead threads for the code all right okay
that is Levin TV at CRT thank you very
much mr. Levin I appreciate you taking
the time go get some rest
god bless brother
[Music]
I can't stop bitching my head yeah
congressman I noticed it you probably
really annoyed huh being all icky yeah
I've no idea why though it's just so
itchy
ya know any person you put poison ivy in
your shampoo no way who do that
you white devil grind the bean but
that's why no one knows why water with
Crowder Ranger panties why yours today
at ladder with Crowder shop calm
[Music]
that's probably Chris Cuomo fewer no I
wasn't prepared for that you were not no
are you doing better yeah I'm okay
finally we can fix that in post just so
you know there are some things that are
beyond fixing in post by the way you've
you've been a horrible hood pass leave
it at that high-pitched squeal yeah I'm
sorry you are not gonna earn us any
points if they have to see a shot we're
gonna send you into a double the
n-double-a-cp
some kind of a conference and see what
they do with you let's see we'll see
what happens don't worry we'll protect
you one of those who've been all black
deal no I mean I've been doing like a
black church really well yeah so but do
they treat you as one of their own no no
okay
how would you need the open church when
I was in LA they did not at all as well
thank you so much Paul Joseph Watson and
Mark Levin we really appreciate it next
week and third chair we're gonna have
razor fist in there yeah we're gonna
have a Brautigan background the
hodgetwins back we're gonna have nick de
pollo hopefully really soon coming out
there bas Rutten in November so really
excited you know we've been talking the
last couple of weeks about tests and
that's because most news they take off
all of August the D platforming whether
it's the progressive sort of setting the
stage for the DNC in November that's
kind of the conspiracy or whether it's a
violation of free speech whether these
companies constitute a monopoly whether
they need to be regulated as public
utilities and everyone kind of has a
different opinion and I know a lot of
you feel like or a lot of you have
expressed that you you don't think you
have definitive answers that's because
in this case there aren't a lot of
definitive answers but let me give you
something definitive okay
this right now what's happening this is
a hill I'm willing to die on that we
hear a lot of credible in the diet
that's as definitive as I can give you
as it relates to us what do I mean by
that but we created mug club
specifically for this reason so that
everyone can actually here continue to
make a living and continue to create
content that you know and love hopefully
sometimes moderately like why because
we've suffered from this from a long to
monetization surprisingly not as bad as
some actually the D monetization but
worse in the restricted mode I think all
our videos except for 12 are in
restricted mode and obviously more so
strikes and false copyright so much so
that we that's actually why we've had to
put half Asian lawyer bill Richman on
retainer so we're hiring new people you
can go check on the web
check things on the website for people
who are looking to apply there's been a
process but in golden ticket for those
who are club members you already know
the rules the stipulations for
people-watching
you just gonna have to join welcome to
figure it out but we're moving in to get
an even larger space bringing in people
like we talked about like Owen Benjamin
hodgetwins raise your fist next week
Nick DiPaolo and and these people are
going to be here for days in studio for
you
why is including more people becoming
such a priority for this show because we
want people with the balls out there to
take a stand to know that we have their
back and this is something that occurred
to me not that long really this week you
know do you know how many a conservative
shows quarterblack Garrett oh and
Benjamin had done before this show no
none you know maybe the hodgetwins had
done before they were on this show none
none zero razörfist
none Nick DiPaolo zero Andrew Bogut zero
Daniel Cormier zero George st. Pierre
zero Ralph Macchio zero these are people
who have never ever in their lives done
a conservative show don't any kind of
flip they don't do political talk radio
but they came on this show they had the
balls to do it now in some cases like on
Benjamin like Nick DiPaolo then they end
up being out of the closet as a
conservative forevermore
and you know what that's a pretty tough
stance to take right now and so we want
them to know that we have their back we
want to include as many people kind of
rotate them throughout the studio you'll
let us know who you like there but it's
important to me when you realize that
responsibility and the only way to do it
the only way to bring them out obviously
flying them is my club that's the only
we know how the full show is up there
every single day should it be taken down
here now we've had a lot of people say
this like we need and you we've both
talked about this uploading to other
platforms and you know for a long time
we thought about Vimeo people want to
upload all your videos to Vimeo well we
just saw Vimeo removed Alex Jones - yeah
Vimeo the patreon is moved thousands of
people they've completely removed them
often for political reasons the point is
that if you don't control it entirely
you are always at the mercy of the
Silicon Valley mob they take a cut and
they get to control what it is you do
and where you get to play and they think
it's the only way but because we don't
use Michael as a bait and switch we
actually use it and the support that we
get from you to provide more content on
YouTube than ever why because we
actually think it's a big part of our
mission we see millions of people and
not just the people who just talked
about who are high
profile but millions of other people
who've changed their minds who've opened
up their minds as a result of this show
and not just the show we're not the only
ones there a lot of other people out
there there's Ben Shapiro there are
people like David when they're Jordan
fusion of course but this is the way
we're able to do it with a late night
comedy show and if YouTube tries to D
platform us or if they start doing it to
everyone else
not including us this is a hill I'm
willing to die on if conservatism dies
on social media as a whole it will be
because we were here having done
everything we possibly could and you'll
find this entire crew dead on that hill
now here's one thing too everyone has to
pick hills up they're willing to die on
you've heard me talk about this not not
just in this but of course overall in
general in life you pick a point
everyone draws a line on this and at
some point you you choose your Hill is
it your marriage are you willing to die
on the hill that keeps it together
regardless of how much I argue or how
wrong you may think you are for each
other how wrong you may think she or he
is in this argument how unhappy it may
feel that the hill you're willing to die
on is it your dreams
all right willing to die on the hill
that makes them happen regardless how
many doors get slammed in your face
regardless of the professional the
personal humiliations I've experienced
almost all of them including nearly
soiling myself but for the Just for
Laughs festival regardless of how many
of the so-called friends you lose is it
your beliefs are you willing to die on
the hill to stand true to your
convictions regardless of how many work
opportunities you lose like Owen how
many teachers don't like you I I get
your emails believe me after the Afcon
furan sigh I hear you how many FS you
get are you willing to die on the hill
of your convictions in our case when it
comes to YouTube by the way it's not
about entitlement I want to make this
really clear it's about an agreement
they YouTube all of these social media
giants but particularly YouTube have
courted our business a lot of creditors
business and repeatedly ask they've
asked us to invest on this platform and
to invest muu the viewers here and we
have and I know some of you can't afford
my club yet so we do what we can we
upload as much free content as we can
but we're aware of the impact that we
have and I'm incredibly grateful I don't
get a big head about it I wake up and
cold sweats because of the impact that
you have given us here so generously and
to keep that impact going that they hate
I'm willing to die on this hill I'm
willing to pay whatever it takes to
fight the hard strikes
and we have many many many tens of
thousands of dollars I'm willing to put
whatever lawyers we have to on retainer
I want to fight it out in the public I'm
willing to I'm willing to fight a lot on
social media all of these platforms I am
willing to fight it out in the courts
behind closed doors I and I know the
rest of this team were willing to make
the hard decisions needed in picking
people next to us all as we prepare for
less we not like you've heard me talk
about this a long time we know that this
has been coming down the pike the
question was just of when and so it's
important that we have everyone is using
in the studio people who are also
willing to die on the hill to make sure
that you and the rest of you watching
you are not alone whatever it takes
that's where we are with this right now
and whether you agree with Alex Jones or
not or not it's whatever whatever it
takes that's where we whatever it takes
to fight this at every single point and
by the way when I say whatever it takes
that doesn't mean there's a guaranteed
victory hell we could all get D
platformed maybe even tomorrow and we
all lose maybe maybe we will die on that
hill maybe you will too but you know
what I I know that if we're not willing
to there's no chance of us climbing it
anyway if we're not willing to roll the
dice and you all have those moments
where you have to pick them and I
guarantee you that I and everyone who
works here will do whatever it takes to
stay there and hold that hill first you
want to be there with me you've all got
to pick your hills and here's the thing
is the glories we will talk about this
we talk about the hill to dine and often
you hear this as well up the hill you
want to die on at work right you know
it's not the hill you want to die I
wasn't arguing with your wife actually
it should be used not as a pejorative it
should be used in a positive light
because isn't it glorious that in the
end instead of going out like some tired
feeble coward you you at least get to
pick out how you get taken out so I I
don't know what's gonna happen what
everyone else is being deep platformed
but I do know that it's not gonna happen
to us without the ugliest tooth and nail
dogfight that we can give them and that
happens with your support so you have to
decide are you willing to die on this
hill are you willing to die in the first
of mal are you willing to die in the
hill right now when they are trying to
silence everyone who disagrees with you
don't even have to agree with me it's
early life I don't agree with Alex Jones
on a whole lot
you would have to agree with any of us
you just have to agree with the basic
concept that there needs to be an open
platform for people to express their
point of view or if you enter into a
business contract that you can't screw
somebody simply because you disagree
with them are you willing to die on that
hill cuz I am so good start by joining
my club or buying a wall that's your
first step you can watch my video see
you next week
[Music]
you